when we have independence does anything
interesting happen to expectations we
know that in general the expected value
of a function of random variables is not
the same as applying the function to the
expected values and we also know that
there are some exceptions where we do
get equality this is the case where we
are dealing with linear functions of one
or more random variables
note that this last property is always
true and does not require any
independence assumptions when we have
independence there is one additional
property that turns out to be true the
expected value of the product of two
independent random variables is the
product of their expected values let us
verify this relation we are dealing here
with the expected value of a function of
random variables where the function is
defined to be the product function so to
calculate this expected value you can
use the expected value rule and we are
going to get the sum over all X the sum
over all Y of G of X Y but in this case
G of XY is x times y and then we weigh
all those values according to the
probabilities as given by the joint PMF
now using independence this sum can be
changed into the following form the
joint PMF is the product of the marginal
pmfs and now when we look at the inner
sum over all values of Y we can take
outside the summation those terms
do not depend on why and so this term
and that term and this is going to yield
a summation over X of x times the
marginal PMF of X and then the summation
over all y of Y times the marginal PMF
of Y but now we recognize that here we
have just the expected value of y and
then on we will be left with another
expression which is the expected value
of x and this completes the argument now
consider a function of x and another
function of y x and y are independent
intuitively the value of x does not give
you any new information about Y so the
value of G of X does not give you any
new information about H of Y so on the
basis of this intuitive argument the
functions G of X and H of Y are also
independent of each other therefore we
can apply the fact that we have already
proved but with G of X in the place of X
and H of Y in the place of Y and this
gives us this more general fact that the
expected value of the product of two
functions of independent random
variables is equal to the product of the
expectations of these functions we could
also prove this property directly
without relying on the intuitive
argument we could just follow the same
steps as in this derivation wherever
there's an X we would write G of X and
wherever there is a Y we would write H
of Y and the same algebra would go
through and we would end up with the
expected value of G of x times the
expected value of H of Y